[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام الم تثبت
الايام ان الدكتاتور الليبي الجديد خليفه
حفتر نسخه رديئه عن الجنرالات العرب الذين
يحاولون اعاده عقارب الساعه الى الوراء
واعاده الشعوب الى زريبه الطاعه هل هو
اكثر من مطيه تديره قوى خارجيه اخر ما
يهمها مصلحه الشعب الليبي ماذا حقق حفتر
لليبيين من وعوده المعسوله الم تؤدي عمليه
الكرامه المزعومه الى تشريد وقتل مئات
الالوف من الليبيين هل هذه هي الكرامه
التي وعد بها الشعب الليبي اليس تكالب
قوات حفتر لاستعاده الهلال النفطي دليلا
صارخا على ان كل ما يريده هو نهب ثروات
ليبيا واحتكار السلطه بالتعاون مع حلفائه
الخارجيين لكن في المقابل اليس من المبكر
التبشير بانتهاء اسطوره حفتر بعد خسارته
الهلال النفطي اما تزال الحرب اما تزال
الحرب كرا وفرا في ليبيا اليس من السذاجه
القول ان حلفائه في الخارج قد باعوه الا
تحاول روسيا تعويمه كما عومت من قبل
الجنرال الساقط بشار الاسد الا يحظى حفتر
بتاييد شريحه لا باس بها من الليبيين اليس
من الاجحاف اتهامه بتقويض الحل والسلام في
ليبيا اليس من الخطا اعتبار ثوره او
اعتباره ثوره مضاده تريد اعاده الليبيين
الى حضن
العسكر اسئله اطرحها هنا في الاستديو على
السيد سعد العبيدي رئيس رابطه مهجري
بنغازي وعبر الاقمار الصناعيه من تونس على
الكاتب والباحث الليبي عز الدين عقيل نبدا
نقاش بعد
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم في برنامج الاتجاه المعك سيد سعد
لو بدات معك هنا في
الاستديو اين تتجه الاوضاع في ليبيا على
ضوء الهزائم المتكرره التي تلحق
بدكتاتورية
والسلام على اشرف المرسلين اللهم احقن
دمائنا ووحد بلادنا يا رب العالمين تحيه
لك دكتور فيصل وتحيه للمشاهدين الكرام
وبعد اقول باذن الله تعالى تسير الامور
الى نهايه حفتر باذن الله تعالى هكذا
المبشرات وهكذا ال رؤ وهكذا المشهد يبدو
واضحا وخاصه بعد هذه الهزائم المتتاليه
واتضح للشعب الليبي ان هذه العوبه وان هذه
الضحوكه ما هي الا نمر من ورق مجرد ان
ارتفع عليه الغطاء الخارجي فاذا به يسقط
هاويا الان نحن اسبوعين يعني تم تسليم
المواني للحكومه الشرعيه في في ليبيا
وبفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى لا تزال المواني
في يد الحكومه التي كان يلوح بهذه الورقه
حفتر ويقول للعالم انا املك برقه بالكامل
وانا املك المواني النفطيه واملك اهم مصدر
دخل لليبيين عليكم ان تعطوا لي الشرعيه
عليكم ان تموني من ليبيا كامله الامور
باذن الله تعالى في تحلل كامل باذن الله
تعالى السرايا عاقدون العزم على الوصول
الى بيوتهم سرايا الدفاع عن بنغازي سرايا
الدفاع عن بنغازي عاقدون العزم باذن الله
تعالى والى اليوم بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى
ها هي الهزائم تتوالى على حفتر
قضيتنا واضحه باذن الله تعالى راجعين الى
مدينتنا بنغازي نريد بيوتنا نريد ارزاقنا
نريد اهلنا ليس لدينا اكثر من ذلك طيب بس
سؤال مطروح سيد سعد يعني سمعنا مثل هذا
الكلام كثيرا في الماضي قلتم ان حفتر
انتهى منذ اكثر من من عامين لكن هذا هو
حفتر او قوات حفتر تعود اليوم اليوم
تحديدا الى مهاجمه الهلال النفطي اذا
المعركه ما زالت كرا
وفرا للتصحيح يا دكتور فيصل لم يهاجم
المواني النفيه بل هاجم في العقيله
العقيله اللي قريبه من البريقه كانت
المعركه هناك شرسه وبفضل الله سبحانه
وتعالى اليوم لدينا 12 اسيرا من بينهم
اثنين سي سعد لا تستطيع ان تنكر ان حفتر
على مدى الاسبوع الماضي حسب كل التقارير
يحضر لمعركه فاصله في الموانئ عفوا في
الموانئ النفطيه او في منطقه الهلال
النفطي ولازال يحضر وسيكمل ان شاء الله
تحضير وباذن الله تعالى لن يقف هذه الايام
خاصه هذه الايام لن يقف امام السرايا
خصوصا كما قلت لك يا اخي فيصل وكما اسلفت
ان قضيتنا واضحه لا نريد لا ليس لدينا
اطماع سياسيه ليس لدينا اطماع اقتصاديه
ليس لدينا اطماع في السيطره على اي شيء
الا الرجوع الى بيوتنا والى اهلنا وانقاذ
ما تبقى من منطقه قنفوده الكارثه الحديثه
كارثه العصر قنفوده الذين ياكلون العشب
الان ويشربون مياه المجاري كي يعيشوا
ياكلون العشبه الان والله اليوم بسبب بسبب
الحصار بسبب الحصار الجائر بسبب رفض اي
مبادره من قبل من قبل من قبل حفتر من قبل
حفتر واعوان حفتر رفض اي مبادره ولعل يا
اخي من ضمن الحديث اخر مبادره للاسف يعني
والله اقولها كل حصره وكل الم كان الاتفاق
المبادره الاخيره كان الاتفاق ان يعطوا
اهل قنفوده يعطوا قنينه مياه حتى يشربوا
ويتم اطلاق الاسرى الموجودين عند السراي
وافق في بدايه الامر ثم رجع في هذا الكلام
اصبح مقدار الليبي عندنا يساوي 75 قرش
الان مقابل قنينه مياه عند حفتر عند حفتر
طيب سيد عز الدين سمعت هذا الكلام كيف ترد
على ما تفضل به السيد الضيف هنا في
الاستديو بان يعني اسطوره حفتر او حفتر
اوشكت على نهايتها اثبتت الايام الاخيره
بانه نمر من ورق بانه مجرد العوبه ما ان
رفع الغطاء الخارجي عن
حتى بدا ينهار ك يعني كالدوم نو اذا صح
التعبير كيف
ترد بدايه تحياتي لك ولسا المشاهدين
ولضيفك الذي رغم انه يمارس حديث المنابر
الا انه تجاوز ان يحيي تحيه الاسلام
المامور بها من رب العالمين ضيفا يجمعه
معه على الاقل سقف واحد حتى هذه اللحظه
وثانيا اعتقد انكم اخليت باول وعودكم وهو
ان اتابعكم من خلال المونيتور انا الان
امام الدنيا
فضاء وكانني اتحدث الى برنامج مسموع في
راديو وليس الى تلفزيون ولا اعتقد ان هذا
يليق بقناه الجزيره طالما قطع وعد كان يجب
ان يتم الافاء به طيب اما فيما يتعلق
باسطوره خليفه حفتر فاعتقد ان هذا التكوين
هو تكوين لنواه جيش حقيقي الخطوه قام بها
المشير خليفه حفتر لانه كان مامورا بهذه
الخطوه قانونيا واخلاقيا عندما اسقط
النيتو الدوله في ليبيا وعندما اتزل
النظام في ليبيا بمنظومه الامن القومي من
الجيش وحتى الحرس البلدي التي شردها اشد
تشريد كان لابد وان يكون هناك الضابط
الاقدم والضابط الاعلى رتبه والذي يتمتع
بقدر من الشجاعه كان عليه ان يختار مكانا
امنا طالما انه بعد النيتو تسلمت الجماعات
المتطرفه ذبح الجيش وبدات تريق دمائه في
الشوارع وترفع شعارات الرفض الكامل
والقاطع لعودته كان يجب ان يقوم شخص شجاع
وشخص عسكري محترف يتمتع بالرتبه الاعلى
والاقدميه في الجيش لان يختار المكان
الامن ولان يضرب الصافره لكي يجمع هذا
الجيش ومع ذلك حتى لو افترضنا بان هذا
الجيش ميليشيا كما يريد ان يوحي لنا
صديقكم او ضيفكم اعتقد ان هذه الميليشيا
طالما انها تدار بقياده عسكريه محترفه
وليس بامراءه سوابق ارهابيه متطرفه وكذلك
سوابق كبيره في عالم الاجرام كما يجري مع
باقي الميليشيات مجتمعه وطالما ان قائد
الجيش هذا يستقبل باحترام كبير من طرف دول
اقليميه ودوليه لها احترامها الكبير
كروسيا والجزائر ومصر والامارات وتونس
وغيرها من الدول وطالما ان هذا الجيش عاد
لاستخدام الادبيات الاساسيه للحظات
الاخيره لوجود المؤسسه العسكريه وهي
القوات المسلحه العربيه الليبيه ويحاول
قدر الامكان ان يكون هناك حضورا لهذا
الجيش وطالما ان هذا الجيش يتبع مؤسسه
سياسيه واحده وهي البرلمان وكذلك حكومه
تني حتى ولو افترض البعض ان العكس هو
الصحيح فيجب ان ف فمجرد رد التناغم بين
القياده العسكريه والعمليه السياسيه او
القياده السياسيه هو امر مهم وكبير جدا
وطالما ان هذا الجيش او هذه الميليشيا ان
حتى نرضي ضيفك تتكون من الليبيين على
اختلاف انتماءاتهم من غرب البلاد ومن
جنوبها ومن شرقها وجلهم من العسكريين
وليسوا من الجماعات الايديولوجيه لنستطيع
ان نسمي جيش حفتر بانه جيش ايديولوجي او
جيش قبلي او جيش جهوي او عصابه ما فيوزيه
كتلك الميليشيات التي تنتشر بشكل كبير
وواسع في غرب البلاد والتي تذبح المواطنين
الليبيين حتى هذه الساعه فاعتقد ان كل هذه
هرطقات لا اعتقد ان لها معنى وليتك اخي
الكريم لا توجه الي هذه الاسئله انطباع
ليتك توجه الي اسئله تليق بقناه الجزيره
اسئله حقيقيه نستطيع من خلال شو مثلا يا
سيد سقرا يا سيد افلاطون يا سيد افلاطون
اول شيء اول شيء ارجوك رجاء حار ما تنظر
علي وما تتفلسف علي وما تعمل لي حالك
سقراط اوكي شو يعني اسئله هذا هو سؤال
واضح
لا عن حسمي ماذا شو بدي اعطيك اسئله
فلسفيه انا اس بدي اسالك سؤال بدي اسالك
سؤال بدي اسالك سؤال بدي اسال
سؤال
معون ان يوضح لك وجهه
نظر هل هناك معارك في ليبيا الان اسمح
بدايه لسقراط وطون يا سيدي هل هناك معارك
في ليبيا الان الم يخ هذا البطل الهمام
الذي تصوره لنا الان هذه الشخصيه العظيمه
اه الم يخسر معظم الهلال النفطي وهو
المكان الاهم بالنسبه له طيب نحن نتحدث عن
الارض هذه هي حقائق على الارض كيف
ترد على على ايه حال سؤالك الانطباعي
عندما تقول لي بان قال بان هذا الرجل
سينهار وان اسطورته قد انتهت هذه مساله
انطباع كبيره يمكن ان اتحدث لك
انشاتها حتىلا ايام انا اريد اسئله محدده
اجيب عنها كوني محلل وكوني شخص
مح الان يا سيد عزدين بس مشان بس مشان نمع
الموضوع ما بدي ادخل اسالك الان يا سيدي
انسالي اسطوره حفتر انسالي كل هذا الكلام
ليبيا الى اين بعد هزائمه الشنيعه في
الهلال النفطي اليوم 12 اسير لقواته هو في
وضع سيء جدا الى ما هنالك من هذا الكلام
هل خسر الهلال النفطي ام لم يخسره هذا
سؤال محدد ما له علاقه لا بارسطو ولا ب
فلاتون على
ايه هذا انت انت من ذكرت ارس وافلاطون
ولست انا انا انا طلبت منك اسئله محدده
وها انت قد عدت هذا سؤالي محدد جبني علي
لو تكرمت المهم ا اعتقد ان هذه الخساره هي
خساره طبيعيه في تصوري الخاص ان هناك
اطراف مارست حرب وكاله حقيقيه لان اتجاه
النفط الليبي خاصه بعد توقيع اتفاقيه روس
نفط بدا يتحرك عمليا نحو المليون ونص
برميل وهي الكميه تقريبا التي عملت دول
اقليميه ضمن اطار مشروع قاد ان تستعين فيه
باللجان من اجل تخفيض هذه الكميه من
الاسواق الدوليه حتى تحافظ على الحد
الادنى من السعر المقبول الذي تستطيع ان
تقيم عليه ميزانياتها ايضا هناك الانجليز
الذين ادوا بشكل كبير من توقيع اتفاقيه
روس نفط وخرجت علينا صحفه بريطانيه تقول
بان روس يحاولون زياده وتعميق مصالحهم في
ليبيا حتى يبررون هذا التدخل مستقبلا
وسمعنا كيف ان وزير الدفاع البريطاني
تلاسن مع وزير الدفاع الروسي وكيف ان
الروس تحدوا الانجليز واستدعوا السراج
اليهم لكي يوصلوا دعني اكمل شن طيب تفضل
تضل تفضل تفضل تفضل يعني باختصار ماذا
تريد ان تقول باختصار بجمله واحده كي كي
لا يكون على نقطه واحده لو تكرمت اريد ان
اقول ايه اريد ان اقول اريد ان اقول بان
هذه الحرب التي استخدمت فيها الجماعات
التي هاجمت الهلال النفطي اسلحه جديده
ومتطوره ا وهذه الحرب التي ضخت فيها اموال
كثيره لشراء ولاءات اشخاص داخل المواني
النفطيه وهم من بقايا جماعات الجدران
والذين كان الانتفاضتين المسلحه داخل
المواني النفطيه بالغ الاثر في حدوث هذا
الذي حدث وكذلك استخدام ميليشيات من خارج
ليبيا ميليشيات اجنبيه ايضا دخت اليهم
اموال ضخمه هو الذي ادى الى هذه الهزيمه
المحدوده والجيش اليوم يقاتل من جديد
واعتقد انه سيعود الى هذه المناطق وسوف
نلتقي وسوف اذكرك بذلك جميل جدا كيف ترد
على هذا الكلام الرجل يقول لك يعني انتم
حالمون بعباره اخرى هذا الرجل او هذه
الاسطوره الذي رفض يعني انه نسميها ان
انهارت باي شكل من الاشكال هذا الرجل هو
امل ليبيا كما يقول الرجل هو الضابط
الاقدم هو الاعلى رتبه هو جاء في الوقت
المناسب لينقذ الدوله الليبيه والجيش
الليبي اه بعدين يعني انتم طبلت وزمرته لخ
لخسائره الاخيره وكما يقول لك سنلتقي
قريبا وسينتصر
حفتر بدايه اليوم 14 اليوم بعد تسعه ايام
بعد سبع ايام بعد سبع ايام 21/3 هذا عيد
ميلاد حفتر 21/3 ما اظني عارفينا انتم
21/3 عيد ع عيد القبض على حفت رشاد اسير
في ال 87 الان 30 سنه يعني والدان بعيد
الام هو ايو
21/3 قبض عليه حسين حبري مع يده للاسف مع
وذن للاسف قبض عليه في غرفه وسلم نفسه وهو
موجود في الغرفه في الوقت اللي كانوا
الاسرى الليبيين كانوا جرحا تاكل فيهم
الفئران ولا يستسلموا لحسين حبري واذا به
هو يسلم طواعيه لحسين حبري واتفق مع حس
حبري على ان يشتغل معه في العماله ثم ذهب
الى امريكا على اساس بيقود المعارضه هو ضد
القذافي واذا به يعمل له القذافي فخ على
كلامه واعطاه فيلا و 7000 دولار في الشهر
هذا فخ هو حفتر لما سالوه عليه قال لا هو
انا عارف ا فخ بس اخذته عشان عائلتي تق
والبعض يقول ان شقته في امريكا كانت مقابل
السي اي اي الاستخبارات الامريكيه نفسه
قالها برضه قال كانوا قريبين مني قال
كانوا قريبين مني ولما سال عريش سعيد هذا
الصحفي اللي معهم هو ايضا من الكرامه قال
ل ان في اتصال بينك وبين السي اي ايه قال
له نعم هل معقوله واحد يقعد يجار السي اي
ايه وما يتصل بهم هذا بالنسبه لحفتر
بالنسبه للجيش الهمام اللي يحكي عليه انا
ما مش عارف ناخذ تحليل الاخ عز الدين ولا
ناخذ القيادات اللي معه حفتر اصلا قيادات
حفتر يقولوا ما هو الا فتاه جيش لولا فزعه
عرب بنين عاو الفيديو يا شيخ عز يا سيد
عزدين الفيديو يقول فيه البرعصي اللي تو
مطارد هذا امر محور كان يهدم في في بنغازي
الان مطارد من قبل حفتر لو كان يحصله حفتر
يقتله ودخل عليه في المزرعه بتاعته و
وانتهك بيته ودخل على نساءه هذا قائد محور
عند حفتر بنفسه هذا يقول نحن فتاه جيش نحن
العتاد بعنا 27000 ضابط الان معنا 27 ضابط
قال بس 27 ضابط من 27 ال القوه العاديه
بعنا جيش يا اخي يا سيدي طيب بس يا سيد
سعد طيب اذا كان هذا الجيش بكل هذا الضعف
فكيف تفسر انه يحقق انجازات وانتصارات
ويواجه الغرب باكمله الغرب الليبي السيد
عمر بشير رئيس السودان اعترف برسميه قال
العدل والمساواه هم من يساندون حفتر في
معركته العدل والمساواه السودانيه المستوا
السودانيه هي من تساند حفتر هي التي تدعمه
بالقوات والبعض يتحدث عن قوات الشاديه
ايضا وقوات الشاديه يعني الامور واضحه اي
جيش تحكي اي جيش اللي فيه بلاكي وفيه بحه
وفيه وفيه تيوتا وفيه اه من المليشيات
صحيح تيوتا هذا من سرقه السيارات را م
سمينا تيوتا هذا امر ميليشيا عند حفتر اي
اي جيش تحكوا عليه بس لما لما قامت ثورتنا
عبد الفتاح رحمه الله عليه صب في وسط
الصاعقه وعمل نداء للجيش الليبي على اساس
يجي معه الجيش الليبي واذا بيجيه 40
واحد وين هو الجيش جميل وين هو الجيش اللي
تحكوا عليه جميل جدا خلينا ناخذ هذه سييد
عز الدين سمعت هذا الكلام يعني انت تقول
تتهم الطرف الاخر او تتهم بقيه الليبيين
بانهم عباره عن ثله من المرتزقه ولا لا
ومن الارهابيين والتكفيريين وماعرف شو واص
ليس ليبيا يعني الى ما هنالك من هذا
الكلام الرجل يقول لك يعني انت تتحدث عن
حفتر كما لو ان جيشه جيش وطني وهو زعيم
وطني يعني انت انت تعلم بدون الغطاء الجوي
لا يساوي شيئا في الفتره الاخيره عندما
خسر الهلال النفطي كيف خسر الهلال النفطي
بسبب بسبب عجز سلاح الجو سلاح الجو
الخارجي الذي كان يدعم حفتر لم يدعمه بنفس
القوه هذه المره فلهذا انهار خلال خلال
ساعات والامر الاخر تقول هؤلاء مرتزقه
وماذا عن جيش حفتر السودانيون المتمردون
السودانيون تبع العدل والمساواه معه
التشاديين معه الفرنسيون معه طيارات عربيه
من الف مكان معه قبل ايام شاهدنا الوجبات
التي التي حصل حصلوا عليها وجبات كلها جاي
من دول عربيه الفرنسيين الذين قتلوا معه
يعني وكانه حفتر هو هو يعني ليبي وعز
الليبيين و هو عباره عن شلاع ايط كما يقول
لك شلاع ايط كيف
ترد هو على ايه حال هذا الذي قلته انت هذا
راي انت واحد معنا المفروض من
الالته قبل شوي انا سالته نفس الاسئله
للرجل وسؤالك اص اخي بض اني انزعجت عمليا
سؤالك مرفت را من ساس انت طلعت من طيران
لانك قلت تكلمت عن الليبيين انا لم اذكر
الليبيين انا اتحدث عن ميليشيات لا تقول
عن باقي الليبيين وكانك تتحدث باسم الشعب
الليبي انا اتحدث عن ميليشيات تقابل الجيش
او حتى اذا قلنا ان خليفه حفتر ميليشيا
قلت لك بانها تملك معايير نوات جيش ولانها
ميليشيا تتكون من كل الليبيين ولانها
ميليشيا تقودها قياده عسكريه محترفه وانها
ميليشيا تواع جويه
والله هو
عندك لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي
العظيم من حق الج من حق الجيوش ان تعقد
اتفاقاتها مع من تشاء وهذا راجع التواريخ
العسكريه للتحالفات وستجد ان اي قياده
عسكريه لها الحق في ان تتفق مع تشاء وان
تتحالف مع تشاء ولكن عندما تكون شراد من
الميليشيات التي تجمعت من خلال دعم اقليمي
لدول تريد استمرار الخراب لليبيا فهذا لا
يعد عملا عسكريا وانما ما يعد عملا
اجراميا لما تقول لي حفتر يستخدم في سلاح
الجو من الذي يستخدم سلاح الجو سلاح الجو
يحتاج الى قواعد سلاح الجو يحتاج الى
طيارين سلاح الجو يحتاج الى طائرات سلاح
الجو يحتاج الى امداد ودعم فني هذه لا
تملكها الا الجيوش لماذا لم تملك ميليشيات
هذه الطائرات ولماذا لم تواجه بها خليفه
حفتر لان خليفه حفتر يقود جيش صحيح ان هذا
الجيش لا يحقق كل تطلعاتنا صحيح ان هذا
الجيش يعمل في ظروف بالغه الصعوبه صحيح ان
هذا الجيش يمارس عليه الحظر الجوي صحيح ان
هذا الجيش اتحدت ضده كل المجموعات
الارهابيه المتطرفه من انصار الشريعه الى
القاعده الى المقاتله الى الاخوان
المسلمين الى دول اقليميه الى دول عالميه
الكل ضد هذا الجيش الذي يريد ان يفرض
وجوده في ظروف بالغه صعوبه نحن نعرف ان
هذا الجيش لا يمكن ابدا ان يحقق ذلك
التطلع الذي نريده نحن كليبين هناك اتفاق
ضروري على هيكليه هذا الجيش لان القدافي
كان يدير الجيش الليبي بلجنه مؤقته للدفاع
ولا نقول ان هيكليه هذا الجيش الذي يديره
حفتر الان هذا الجيش الطاري او هذا الجيش
الثوري ان شئت يمكن ان يحقق تطلعات
الليبيين ايضا علينا ان نتفق على عقيده
هذا الجيش ما زالت ما زال المشوار امامنا
طويل ولكن هذه المرحله مرحله استعاده
سياده وهيبه الدوله مصلحه القضاء على هذه
الميليشيات اللعينه التي تقتل الناس في كل
مكان ميليشيات ك هذه في طرابلس لماذا لم
تستقر الامور في طرابلس لماذا لا تزال
الحرب في طرابلس لماذا ميليشيات لم تفتح
الطريق من الزاويه الى تونس لماذا لازال
الناس لا يستطيعون ان يصلوا الى ورشفانه
لماذا ميليشيات دمرت المطار لماذا
ميليشياته دمرت مستودعات التي تضم احتياط
الاستراتيجي للطاقه في ليبيا اين كان حفتر
هل حفتر موجود في طرابلس هل حفتر هنا في
طرابلس يقاتلونه لماذا فعلوا كل هذه
الافاعيل باهل العاصمه لماذا هذا التمزق
لماذا لديهم حكومتين في طرابلس حكومه هذا
الغوير التي تمثل المصاريت والحكومه
الاخرى التي تمثل العالم وليس لها اي دور
لماذا لهم حكومتين لماذا لهم ميليشيات
متعارضه لماذا يتقاتلون يهاجمون غنوا
ويهاجمون كارا وامس يفتحون حربا في حي
الاندلس ويحرقون واحدا من اكبر المباني
المصرفيه في ليبيا لماذا يحاولون اليوم
الهجوم على الناس ايضا في جرجارش الناس
مرعوبه حفتر ليس موجودا في غرب البلاد
لماذا تثيرون كل هذا العار اعطونا نموذج
الدوله في غرب البلاد حتى نقول بان حفتر
ميليشيا وحتى نقول بان حفتر مجرم سيد عز
الدين كثير من الاس المهمه سيد عز الدين ش
سيد عز الدين كثير من الاسئله المهمه
اسئله مهمه سيد سعد هل تستطيع ان ترد على
هذا الكلام الرجل الرجل سال اسئله في
الصميم في الصميم هل تستطيع ان ترد عليها
انا من عارف اين استقرار اللي يحكي عليه
في الشر انا من الشرق انا اللي اولى نحكي
عليه الشرق انت من بغازي انا من بنغازي
انا من شرق ليبيا انا من برجا اللي يحكي
عليها وين الاستقرار في برقه خمس جثث امس
في سي خليفه امس خمس جثث في سي خليفه تفضل
هذا الاستقاله اللي يحكي عليها ها هذا ما
المشايخ ها في الكنيسه قاعدين هذا بعد عهد
الكرامه شوفوها والله العظيم بعد عهد
الكرامه هذا الجيش هذا الجيش اللي يقتل
ويذبح ويزق في الكناسه اي جيش يا اخي اذا
كان القيادات اعترفوا بانفسهم المهدي
البرغثي اللي كان امر منطقه وامر معسكر
يتكلم يقول الان الارهاب يصنع صناعه في
مدينه بنغازي يزرع زراعه في مدينه بنغازي
الارهاب اذا كان القيادات بولغيب ب لغيب
بنفسه يتكلم على حفتر ابريك اللواطي قائد
المشيخه والشيخ بروحه يقول نحنا كان عندنا
قتله 500 في مدينه بنغازي الان اكثر من
6000 مواطن ميتين في بنغازي استقرار تحكي
عليه انت اي وضع تحكي عليه بس ولا ما
تحكيش على ليبيا انت قول لنا اذا كانك
تحكي على ليبيا قوللنا احنا ابناء ليبيا
احنا ابناء الشرق عارفينها بالشارع نحنا
عارفين من اللي نعزك في الكنيسه يا راجل
من اللي انخطف يا راجل باسم الجيش بتحكم
اي جيش يا راجل معقول الكلام هذا اي جيش
اللي يمنع الميه على قنفوده يا راجل نساء
اي جيش اللي يتهم ابنائنا كلهم يتهم ثوره
17 فبراير انهم من داعش وعلى وضح النهار
يتفق معهم ويتفق معهم النقيب محمود
الورفلي اللي الان عاملين محاوله اغتيال
بش يختف السر معاه هو اللي يتفق مع
ميليشيات الدواعش الداعش اتفق معهم وحطهم
فلوس وحطهم سلاح وطلع دقيقه دقيقه دقيقه
حفتر متحالف مع داعش امير امير انا اقولها
بصراحه امير داعش في ليبيا هو حفتر تاتم
باوامر وتسمع بكلامه وتاخذ منها في فلوس
يا اخي يمشوا 800 كيلو يطلعوهم المليشيات
اللي قلت عليهم يا عز الدين الميليشيات هم
اللي طلعوا الارهاب من دارنا هم اللي
طلعوه خلوهم يمشوا 800 م م وهو حفتر قاعد
يحوم بالطيارات بتاعتها في الجو كانما
قربهم كانما شارك في معركه سرد
اللي ما ضحوا مصراتيه ب 750 مقابل الاف ما
يسمى بعمليه داعش ولا تنظيم داعش ولا
تنظيم الدوله ولا اللي هو وين هذ ما كان
ما يتكلموا هذ ما ليش ما يناقشوا معهم هذ
ما يطلعوه في وسط النهار والقائه ويحاصر
قنفوده ويطلع بالعيد الشيخ هذا اللي عليه
من الله سبحانه وتعالى ما يستحق يطلع يقول
اللي في قنفوده كلهم داعش ومستحيل اطلاقا
يطلع واحد عمره 14 سنه قنفوده الان قاعده
تحاصر كارثه قاعده الميه ما عندهمش طيب
يعني اسالك سؤال باختصار يعني هل تريد ان
تقول ان حفتر في ليبيا يفعل ما يفعله بشار
الاسد في سوريا بشار الاسد كل النهار
والليل يتحدث عن الدواعش وخطر الدواعش وهو
الداعش الاول هكذا في ليبيا سيدنا بشار
والله بشار ما جا معه حاجه والله بلكي انت
عندك كم اختلافات وعندك شي ممكن تع نحنا
عائله واحده اللي لعب فيها حفتر بهذا
الشكل ليبيا عائله وحده فعل فيها فعيل
والله الطليان ما فعلوه الله العظيم
ما فعلوه في ليبيا اللي فعل حفتر من هتك
الاعراض اغتصابنساء اغتصاب اطفال والعياذ
بالله ومن اغتصاب حواشين ومن اغتصاب وم
اغتصاب هذا كله حدث في ليبيا وفي مدينه
بنغازي وفي المنطقه
الشرقيه المؤتمر بع سي خليفه هذا اللي
عاملين فيه مبايعه وذكرنا بعهد المبايعات
وعهد اللجان الثوريه وعهد كلها اللي عملوه
هذا مبايع المكان اللي عمل فيه متمر في خ
جس خمز جثث من نفس القبائل اللي هي مجتمع
جميل طيب سيد سيد عقيل سمعت هذا الكلام بس
اسالك سؤال السيد حفتر الليبيون يتسائلون
الان هذا وصلني كثيرا عبر الفيسبوك
الليبيون يتسائلون السيد حفتر عندما ظهر
ظهر بعنوان كبير بشعار كبير عمليه الكرامه
الكرامه ماذا حقق من هذه الكرامه لليبيين
على مدى السنوات الماضيه امن الكرامه ان
يشرد اكثر من 300 ال شخص ان يقتل الالاف
من الليبيين ان يغتصب الليبيات ان يمنع
المياه عن الاطفال والشيوخ والى ما هنالك
واين الكرامه اين عمليه الكرامه ماذا
انتجت الكرامه للشعب الليبي وهذا مش مني
السؤال من الفيسبوك كيف ترد
وريتك هو يا ريت حضرتك تسال قبل عن الالاف
المشردين من المشاشيه ومن تاورغاء ومن
ككله الذين شردوا في كل مكان والالاف من
المهجرين الذين جروا الى خارج المنطقه
الغربيه من هؤلاء الذين تدافع عنهم والذين
هذا الذي تتحدث عنه هو واحد منهم مع انه
كل ذنبه انه كاتب وانه محلل وانه رجل يعمل
في مجال الفكر والبحث ولا علاقه له لا
بحمل سلاح ولا بمقاتلات
ذاك وبالتالي عندما تتحدث عن هذه الماساه
ما الذي حقق خليفه حر خليفه حر حقق منسا
وحتى بني
غازي اسمحلي خليحي اسمحلي انت هجر انا انت
هجرتني انا وهو هجرك انت لان الله سبحانه
وتعالى الذي تحاول ان في كل كلمه ان تذكره
وليتك تذكره بقلبك لان الله سبحانه وتعالى
ما عندش عصاء الله يعرف كيف يعاقب وكل حد
يقوم بفعل لابد ان يرده له الله لانك
هجرتني وهجرت امثالي هجرك الله من مدينتك
هذهه هي الحكايه الخلاصه لدي بعض
الملاحظات التي لا نريد ان تخلق ربما حاله
من التشويش والضلال لدى المتلقي اذا ك كن
تسمح واذا كانت قير تم خذ وقتك كاملا
بالنسبه لتشاد هو
تفضل بالنسبه لتشاد بالنسبه لتشاد اللي
قال هو مش عارف عيد ميلاد خليفه حفتر ولا
عيد ميلاد هذا يوم شرف لحفتر اعظم ما يمكن
ان يقدمه الجندي لبلاده وهو في معركه هو
امرين اما ان يستشهد واما ان يقع في الاسر
حفتر عندما كان في تشاد لم يكن يصطاد
الغزال كانت هناك مؤامره كبيره وهذه
موجوده بشكل واس اتمنى ان يطلع عليها ضيفك
الكريم في كتاب اسمه كتاب الحجاب او ذفيل
لكاتب شهير اسمه بوبد وورد تحدث عن عمليه
ادماء الانف التي سعى اليها رونالد ريغن
بالتعاون مع واين بررر وزير دفاعه وويليام
كيسي وزير مخابراته وشارك في هذه المؤامره
الملك الحسن الثاني لان القدافي كان متورط
في دعم البوليزاريو شارك فيها صدام حسين
لان القدافي كان يدعم ايران ضده شارك فيها
البشير لان القدافي كان يدعم جرنج شارك
فيها كل اعداء القدافي وكانوا يريدون ان
ياتون ه من
تشاد القدافي سارع عندما وصلته هذه
المعلومات واجتاحت شاد في ذلك الوقت لم
يريد ان يشرك خليفه حفتر لانه لم يريد ان
يصنع منه بطلا وطنيا لان القذافي كان يخشى
خليفه حفتر منذ ذلك الوقت دخل القذافي ثم
حصلت مفاوضات كريت مع الرئيس ميتران ثم
انسحب من تشاد بعد ذلك حصل مناوشات وهجوم
اخر من تشاد اضطر القدافي ان يعود خسر
المعركه وهنا تدخل خليفه حفتر خليفه حفتر
دخل الى المعركه لكي يدافع عن بلده فوقع
اسير ويجب ان يحيا على هذه لا ان يتشفى
فيه كما نسمع من ضيفك هذا الذي يبدو انه
ليس ليبيا طيب ماشي طيب ماشي جاوبني على
سؤال لو في ماعلق باهل قنفوده اسمح لي
اسمح لي اسمح لي ان اتم اي سؤال سؤال
كرامه مضوع سؤال الكرامه سؤال الكرامه
سؤال الكرامه مريت عليه مرور الكرامه قك
بان ق ل قلت لقى بان الكرامه حققت
الاستقرار من مساعد الى بنغازي وهذه لا
توجد في اي منطقه من ليبيا حلو لا يوجد
مساحه ضخمه فيها من الاستقرار ما فيها في
في كل ليبيا مثل هذه المنطقه اللي هي من
مساعد الى بنغازي
ايضا عندما نتحدث عن الاستقرار هناك علينا
ان نتحدث ايضا على ان المؤسسات هناك لا
تتعرض الى نفس الهجوم لا تتعرض الى الى
نفس الخطف لا يتعرض المسؤولين هناك الى
نفس الضغوط التي يتعرض لها نظرائهم في غرب
البلاد او في جنوبها هل لديك طيب شيء اخر
اشكرك جزي ممتاز ممتاز سيد سعد هنا في
الاستديو سيد سعد انتم تتهمون حفتر اه
خاصه على ضوء هزائمه الاخيره وهزائم اليوم
تتهمونه بانه لا يمت لد لليبيا بصله هو
عباره عن مخلب قط خارجي او عباره عن حربه
اذا صح التعبير
يمسك بها الخارج لتحقيق اهدافه في في في
ليبيا يعني اليس هناك الكثير من من
الاجحاف بحق هذا الرجل انه هو عباره عن عن
مطيه للاطماع خارجيه او ايدي خارجيه كيف
هذا الكلام يعني كيف نستغرب كيف يقعد يوم
عالمي لحفتر يعني يوم اللي يمسكوه في تشاد
يوم اللي كان يهدم في في حواشين المسلمين
يوم اللي كان يعطي الطفل يعطيه الطفل
يعطيه رمانه في يده يحول له التامين بعها
ويعطيها للطفل يقول له عادي يشيله لامك
هديه مجرد ما يخش على ا جووا
تشيل الرمانه هذه تشيل به يوم اللي كان
يبطر في بقون الصبايا
النساء الحوامل في تشاد بالحربه متاعها ب
يشوفها عيل انثى ولا ذكر هذا يحيا فيه
اليوم هذا اي عقليه هذه واي تفكير هذا اي
تفكير يسيب 700 طالب 700 طالب من الثانويه
خذوهم حطوهم في تشاد تحت امرت السيد هذا
دربهم ثلاث ايام
ثلاث ايام دربهم ت في منهم اللي مات وفي
منهم اللي اسير واللي شرت بعدين المليشيات
سامحني يا دكتور المليشيات اللي يحكي
عليها عملت خمس انتخابات الكرامه ما عملتش
انتخاب واحد الكرامه اللي دارتها شنو حولت
المنتخبين وحطتهم عسكريين عمداء البلديه
منتخبين حاطينهم الناس حولوهم وحطهم
عسكريه بش تقعد كلها يسيم في الشرق
الميليشيات اللي ما يفهمو اللي يذبحوا في
الناس داروا خمس انتخابات خمس انتخابات
بحمايتهم بسلاحهم الى ان نجح الانتخابات
المليشيات اللي يحكي عليهم حطوا وزير
العدل وزير العدل وهذه دروشه مش كويسه
وزير العدل بتاع القذافي حطوه رئيس ليبيا
السيد عبد الجليل السيد مصطفى عبد الجليل
وزير العدل عند ليبيا اما حفتر ريد ان ي
ان يعود بليبيا الى الى عهد العسكر حضن
العسكر اكيد اكيد واللي قاعد يصير هذا شنو
تو هذا شنو اللي قاعد يصير تو عمره ما مش
البرلمان تع طبرق مشه مره واحده يوم اللي
علق بعدين يا اخي الكريم احنا نسينا حفتر
متقاعد اصلا حفتر برا الخدمه برا الجيش شو
اللي خلاه يمسك مسؤوليه من اعطاه الصفه بش
يقتل ولا يحارب ولا ولا يدير في في بنغازي
بنغازي اقول لك الرجل رجل وطني اراد ان
ينقذ بلاده ويعيد الهيبه لدولته ينقذ
بلاده من خراب اللي عملها هو اه فرج قعيم
يا اخي انتم ما تسمعوش ولا ما تشوفوش في
الفيديوهات فرج قعيم ما ماسك المكافحه
والارهاب يا سيد عز الدين ما طلع في فيديو
تكلم قال كل ما يحدث في بنغاز نحن عارفينا
وعندنا 137 ملف ما بين قتل ما بين جريمه
ما بين مخطوفين وعلى النيابه العامه انجي
تحقق وان نعرفها ولولا اني خايف على برقه
تنقسم قال لا قلتهم بالاسم المجرمين اللي
ديروا والسجن هذا عند من عند حفتر خمس
سجون الان في المنطقه الشرقيه الاستقرار
اللي تحكي عليه خمس سجون وتسع مقابر خمس
سجون في المنطقه الشرقيه وتسع مقابر
اطمئنان غايه الاطمئنان صراحه واستقرار
حسن الباستيل الجديد هذا جرنادا هذا قمه
في الاستقرار والطمانينه فتح من جديد سجن
الرجمه سجن المرج سجن برسس انت وين اين
استقرار اين استقرار والناس مش قادره
تجتمع مش قادره تجتمع ليش ما يجتمع في وسط
البلاد ليش ما يجتمع في الكيش اذا كان هو
عنده شعبيه وعنده حاضنه واستقرار وامن
والحكايه 100 م يعدي ذ في خليفه القياده
بتاعتها مو كانت في المارج هو ليش غيرها
حطها في الرجمه وبعدها جابل سي خليفه هذا
استقرار ولا امن ولا شنو يقولونا فهمونا
بس اذا كان المهدي البرث قلت لك الوزير
بتحكم ولا الرئيس بتحكم يطلع بعين قال ل
عندنا جيش وكلها ارهاب وكلها صناعه
للارهاب يا اخي حجازي يا اخي حجاز الناطق
الرسمي الناطق الرسمي باسم عمليه الكرامه
اللي كان لما يطلع كلكم تقولوا سبحان الله
وبحمده لما تحققو طلع لكم وقال لكم ما هي
الا عصابه عصابه قال لهم تحتكر هو اولاده
بطانه فاسده سماها الحجازي قال بطانه
فاسده ايش تبب بعد هك مازال الخمس كرين
روسكم تقولوا جيش ودوله وامن وشخصيه قويه
وشخصيه فاعله عادي شوف فح فيشات شن يدير
يا خليك شويه سيد سمعت هذا الكلام السؤال
الذي يطرحه الليبيون الان يعني يقولون هل
صمنا دهرا كي نفطر على بصله نحن ثرنا من
اجل التخلص من الحكم العسكري من ثقافه
العقيد
من ثقافه العقيد فاذ بهذا الحفتر يريد ان
يعيد الليبيين الى الى الحظيره العسكريه
قاللي لا يستطيع لا تستطيع ان تعيد عقارب
الساعه الى الوراء هكذا يقول
الليبيون الرتب العسكريه لن تعيدنا الى
الحضائر نحن لم نثر كي نحصل على قذافي
جديد ارزل واتعس والكلام لليبيين
المعارضين طبعا هذا هو السؤال يعني لماذا
انت انت يا اخي مبين انت ديمقراطي مدني
وطني من اول البرنامج وانت بتصفق
للدكتاتورية
سيد سيد عقيل طبعا سمعتني بس ما عندك بدك
تجاوب ولا سيد
عقيل سيد
عقيل طيب سنعود الى سيد عقيل لكن نعود الى
الى هنا طيب السؤال مطروح طيب انتم يعني
هذه التهمه ل نفس الكلام هذه التهمه انه
حفتر يريد ان يعيد الليبيين الى العباءه
العسكريه والى الحضيره العسكريه والى الى
ما هنالك طيب اليس في اليس هناك الكثير من
المبالغه والاشعار في مثل هذا الكلام كيف
يريد الان نحن يقول لك الرجل نحن في حاله
حرب نحن نريد قبل كل شيء اعاده الهيبه
للدوله الليبيه نريد تجميع اشلاء الدوله
الليبيه فلماذا تتهمون الرجل بانه
ديكتاتور جديد وبانه يريد ان يعيد الحكم
العسكري الى ليبيا والى ما هنالك من هذا
الكلام اخي دكتور فيصل لما اعلن على
الانقلاب بتاع حفتر في وسط النهار والعالم
كله سامع معه 14 اثنين في 2014 اعلنها في
وسط طرابلس ان هو يبي انقلاب وان الدستور
مجمد وان لا مؤسسات
ولا ولا مؤسسات ولا شيء خلاص الحكم لينا
هذا قبل لا يطلع ارهاب وقبل ما تطلع ماليه
الكرامه وقبل ما يطلع اغتيالات وقبل كذا
عملها في طرابلس بناء على شنو انت عملتها
معناها قضيتك مش قضيه ارهاب انت مش قضيه
بتعيد
الهيبه قضيته يبي ينزع الهيبه يبي ملك
نفسه يا اخي يبي ملك وا يعني كل الوعود
التي قطعها لحضنه الشعبيه يريد رئيس جميع
من حتى السفراء حتى جميع من تحاور مع هذا
الرجل يريد حكم ليبيا يريد بهذا الحرف حكم
ليبيا والث بالتعاون مع من بالتعاون مع مع
الخارج اكيد وبعدين الثمن يدفعوا فيه
ابناء القبائل اللي توا واصلين 12000
12000 واحد الثمن بتاعهم الموت بتاعهم بش
السيد حفتر يقعد على العرش سيد رجع سيد
عقيل سيد عقيل اعيد السؤال باختصار شديد
باختصار شديد انه يعني الليبيون يقولون
نحن لا نريد العوده الى حكم العسكر والسيد
حفتر يريد ان يعيدنا الى الحضيره العسكريه
واعيد واكرر انت كمدني ديمقراطي ليبي مدني
وطني من فدايه الحلقه وانت تقول حفتر
والجنرال والجنرال طيب هل تعتقد ان الشعب
الليبي يمكن ان ان يعود الى الى الى
العقليه العسكريه والحكم العسكري لا تحلم
بها الرجل ليس له اص دج ليس له قاع ليس له
قاعده شعبيه اخر اخر سؤال ليس له قاعده
شعبيه قاعدته الشعبيه موجوده في الشرق لا
في الغرب ما له لا ناقه ولا جمل هل
انطلقتم من كيف يريد ان يوحد
ليبيا
تفضل بدايه
بدايه بدايه ارجو لضيفك الكريم الا يكون
تشادي اكثر من تشاديين هذه الهرطقات بقر
البطون واعطى طفلا قنبله ولا لا ادري ماذا
هناك منظمات دوليه ترصد كل هذا العار
وخليفه حفتر اخذ من تشاد الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه حيث المقر الرئيسي
ليومان رايتس وتش ولو كانت جرائم مثل هذه
مرصده او مرصوده لا كان الرجل في السجن
الان ولا ما تعاطت معه الولايات المتحده
نفسها ولا كانت حتى تعرضت لضغوط كبيره من
المنظمات الانسانيه لانها استضافته في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبالتالي ارجو
ان نترك هذه المساله للتشاديين ونرجو الا
نبرر خيانتنا لرجل ضحى من اجلنا ووقع
اسيرا حتى لا يدخل التشاديين والاجانب
المختلفين في ذلك سيد عزدين سيد عز الدين
جيد بس جاوبني على سؤالي هذه هذه النقطه
توضحت ويعطيك العافيه عليها جاوبني على
سؤالي الليبيون لا يريدون العوده الى
حضيره العسكر وهذا يريد ان يعيدهم الى
حضيره العسكر بالتحالف مع جنرالات الخارج
شوف كيف ترد شوف شوف اخي الكريم شوف شوف
اخي الكريم بدايه هذا تفتيش في النوايا
طالما ان الرجل الذي امامك يتحدث بخطاب
الشيوخ وخطاب المنابر عليه ان يترك هذه
المساله لله رب العالمين طبيعه المعركه
الان لا يمكنها ان تسير الا في هذا
الاتجاه عوده سياده عوده الدوله لابد من
ان تواجه هذه الميليشيات اللعينه ولا بد
ان تواجه ولو بليش بميليشيا موحده لها
مواصفات جيش حتى لو افترضنا ان خليفه حفتر
ميليشيا يجب ان تكون الميليشيا على هذا
الشكل حتى تكون نوات لتاسيس جيش ثم اريد
ان اقول لك شيء تسمعني ولا لا تسمعني انت
الانعم نعم نعم نعم نعم س معك طيب بس سيد
سيد عز الدين في نقطه مهمه جدا ذكرتها انت
بس دقيقه انت ذكرتها منذ البدايه تركز على
انه على انه هؤلاء المعارضين او الذين
يعارضون حفتر او السيد سعد او غيره او
جماعته يعني التصبغ عليهم الصفه الدينيه
وما دينيه وما بعرف شو وكذا وتكفير ممكن
تجاوبني جواب بسيط لو تكرمت طيب بس بس بس
دقيقه ممكن جاوبني جواب بسيط كيف تبرر
لحفتر ان يتحالف مع السل سلفيه شو بتسموها
الدخوليه المدخليه المدخليه كيف تبرر
لحفتر ان يتحالف مع السلفيه المدخليه في
ليبيا
الداعشيه الداعشيه ممكن تجاوبني على هذا
السؤال هو متحالف مع السلفيين ولا مش
متحالف
جاوبني هي متحالف مع السلفيين وهم ليسوا
داعشيون وانت تصفهم بالداعي وكما قلت لك
طالما ان القياده العسكريه
قياده اسمح لي ا الجواب سبحان في سلفي
علماني وسلفي
جهادي او سلفي ليبرالي يعني مثلا في سلفي
ليبرالي وسلفي ديمقراطي انت بتسمع انا عم
بسالك انت سالتني بتسمع جواب اللي مقتنع
به والله انت والله انت تريد ان توحي لي
بالجواب الي تريد السلفيين هؤلاء ليسوا هؤ
هؤلاء هؤلاء السلفيون ليسوا
داعشيون هؤلاء السلفيون ليسوا داعشيون
وهؤلاء السلفيون طالما انهم يسعون في نفس
الاطار وهو استعاده سياده وهيبه الدوله
والقضاء على الجماعات الميليشياوي المتشرد
التي تخضع لامراء حرب منفصلين ليس لديهم
قياده موحده منذ 2011 الى الان لم يشكلوا
لا جيش ولا شرطه موحده وهم كل واحد فيهم
شادلي كانتون وكل واحد فيهم يبتز في الشعب
الليبي من خلال كانونه هذا مقعمز في مطار
هذا مقعمز في ميناء هذا مقعمز في حقل نفطي
هذا مقعمز في في مواني نفطيه وكل واحد
تقاسم البلاد وبداوا كلما تحرك اسد في
اتجاه الاخر يحدث صراع كذلك ال الذي يحدث
في الغابه طالما استمرت هذه الصوره يجب ان
نتحالف حتى مع الشيطان كما قالت شرشل من
اجل القضاء عليها واستعاده سياده وهيبه
بلادنا نعك سيد سيد سيد عيز الدين ليش من
حقك انت تتحالف مع شيط سؤال مهم اللي سالت
انت اللي ف ماشي ماشي بس ما انا بدي كمان
مشان وضح الفكره يعني كيف تبرر لنفسك ان
تتحالف مع الشيطان وتتهم الاخرين بانهم
عباره عن عن يعني تكفيريين وما بعرف شو
وما بعرف شو ومن حق انهم يتحالفوا مع اللي
بدهم اياه بس بما ان الوقت للا لان لان
لانني جيش موحد جميل لانني قياده موحده
لانني استطيع لانني استطيع حتى ان اقضي
عليهم انت تعرف هناك نوع من اللعبات ان
السادات طلع الاخوان المسلمين من من السجن
ثم قتلوه ثم جاء من اعادهم الى السجون من
جديد وعدهم الى التهميش من جديد هذه لعب
سياسيه لا استطيع ان اتحدث ال عن تفاصيل
انا 60 جواب جميل جدا خلينا ننهي البرنامج
بسؤال بسيط بسؤال بسيط بس خل البرنامج
الوقت الوقت سيد عز اريد ا عارف ط ما انت
جاوبت جواب جواب واضح تماما بس انا الوقت
بس مش
سؤؤؤال الاخير اجيبك عن هذا السؤال لن
اجيبك الا عن السؤال اللي سالته اجيبك عنه
لن اجيبك الا عن السؤال الذي سالته لن
اجيبك لا شو بدك تجاوبني ما جاوبتني
جاوبتني بس بدي اسالك سؤال اخير عن الحل
كيف تر كيف تر افاق الحل في
ليبيا من الذي يضع من الذي يضع العص على
سؤال قبول الليبيين بالدكتاتور ا سؤال
قبول الليبيين بالدكتاتور انا خلص خلص
مننا لا ما خلصش مننا خلص مننا انا بنقول
لك على حاجه مهمه في هذا الامر باختصار
انا بنجاوبك باختصار يا اخي انت ضيعت علي
الوقت سبحان الله تضلل علم الانقلابات علم
علم علم الانقلابات العسكريه يقول انك لكي
تجري انقلابا عسكري وتسيطر على السلطه
لابد ان يتوافر لك جيش يسيطر على كل
البلاد ولا بد ان يكون هذا الجيش خاضعه له
كل البلاد من ناحيه دوره الاقليمي ولا بد
ان تكون هناك منظومه اعلاميه تستطيع ان
تسيطر عليها من اجل ان تلقي بياناتك وان
تتحدث للناس تعرف اللحظه هذك اللي حتجي ل
ليبيا حين تكون ليبيا تحت جيش موحد وحين
تكون لديها كل الادوات التي يمكنها ان ان
يقيم بها جيش او مجموعه عسكريه انقلاب في
ذلك اليوم لن يكون حفتر موجودا او حيا فقط
بل حتى عظامه لن تكون في الق جميل جدا
جواب رائع جواب رائع بس سؤال اخير الان من
الذي يضع العصي الان كي نجمل البرنامج من
الذي يعني انت تتحدث عن حفتر يريد السلام
ويريد الاستقرار ويريد الدوله الليبيه من
الذي يضع العصي في دولاب الحل السياسي في
ليبيا انت تعلم الان معظم حلفاء حفتر
الخارجيين خلاص عا
خطول بعدين قص مصر الجزائر تونس الجميع
غاضب من حفتر انت تعلم مصر حاولت ان ترتب
اخيرا اجتماعا مع السراج في ال الهره حفتر
في اللحظه الاخيره رفض ان يحضر الى جانب
السراج طيب اذا اذا حفتر وطني لماذا يعرقل
الحل السياسي في البلاد لماذا يقف ضد
صخيرات لماذا يقف ضد حكومه الوفاق الوطني
لماذا ولماذا ولماذا
باختصار خلي نجاوبك بدايه لا تطمع اخي
الكريم ان مصر ولا روسيا ولا الامارات ولا
حلفاء خليف حفتر قد تخلوا عليه هم مدارين
زي الام اللي تدعي على ولدها وتكره اللي
يقول امين حلو يعني رب ربما هناك بعض
المواقف التي لابد ان تمارس من خلالها
الضغوط على خليفه حفتر حتى يقلل من سقف
مطالبه لان مصر في النهايه تسعى لاستقرار
ليبيا على الاقل الدول الجاره مصر وتونس
والجزائر لانها تتاد بكل خصار بجمله واحده
ما تريد تقول بمله نحن نحن نحن في حاله
نحن نحن في حاله نزاع مسلح ونحتاج من يجمع
كل اطراف هؤلاء الشباب اللي هم يسموا في
روحهم مش عارف سرايا توار بنغازي المجاميع
الاخرى حتى التيارات الايديولوجيه خليفه
حفتر نحن نتطلع الى مظله تستطيع ان تجمعنا
تحتها الى
وسف الوقت الوقت داهمني الوقت داهمني
باختصار شديد انتم حالمون اليوم روسيا
تتحدث عن ارسال قوات خاصه الى الحدود
المصريه الليبيه لتعويم حفتر من جديد كيف
هذه من جهه السؤال الاخير اللي بدي اسالك
اياه الا تعتقد انكم تعطون حفتر اكبر من
قيمته بكثير حفتر بشار الاسد علي عبد الله
صالح كذا هؤلاء عباره عن احجار شطرنج في
لعبه دوليه اكبر من بلادنا جميعا هؤلاء
عباره عن احجار شطرنج بيلعبوا فيهم فكيف
ترد على هذا الكلام انه لن تستطيعوا
القضاء عليه كما قال لك هو كالطفل المدلل
امه بتضربه بس بعد شوي بتعطيه سكره لا لا
باذن الله منتهي احجار هو فعلا لكن هو
الحجر اللي قدامنا نحن اللي قاعد يحرك فيه
قدامنا هو اللي قدامنا هذا باختصار
بجملتين بس انا نب نحكي بس على لا انتهى
الوقت اعطيني بشكل عام والجيش بس الشرطه
والجيش هويدي عملوا له محاوله اغتيال
محمود الورفلي عملوا له محاوله اغتيال
الخفيفي يبحث عليه هذه هي الشرطه والجيش
اللي قاعده في بغازي هذه هي الشرطه اللي
يقول تبي يبنى عليها البلاد والجيش قاعدين
يقتلوا في بعضهم الامراء من هو الجيش هذا
يتبع من الجيش هذا يتبع خليفه حفتر ولا
يتبع مصر ولا يتبع كذا من يتبع بس فهم طيب
باختصار بجمله واحده حفتر الى اين بعد هذه
الهزائم الى النهايه باذن الله تعالى هكذا
السنن الكونيه تقول الظالم لابد ينتهى
طيب اشكر جزيل الشكر مشاهدي الكرام لم
يبقى لنا الا نشكر ضيفين عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه من تونس السيد عز الدين عقيل
وهنا في الاستديو السيد
سعد سعد
العبيدي نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى
ذلك الحين وفيصل القاسم يحيكم من الدوحه
الى اللقاء يعطيك
[موسيقى]
العافيه
ه